so you're Korean yes I am where were you
raised I was born in Korea but I was
raised in Sacramento California how long
did you live in Korea two years okay so
you're yeah yeah he's your dad big no
he's [ __ ] my mom's like five one my
dad's like five three how tall are you
I'm six one you know what everybody
that's so who's on my mom's side all
their kids are tall except for my
brother and this one girl who had polio
that's about it
the polio person didn't make it so you
grew up in Sacramento yeah you're an
American
yeah and you're a big Korean dude I'm
gonna do something yeah friend were you
popular in high school no I don't know
if I was really popular or not but you
know you kind of just figure out where
you're trying to fit in and you don't
really know because I grew up in a
predominantly like urban area no you
know we were what's that Dave that kind
of thing yeah well I wanted to be out yo
dong got a new tribe called quest album
what the other thing is I'm probably the
biggest fan of this podcast so I know I
was just telling this courage I love
urban ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba yeah is like a
melon holy [ __ ] you're it's the biggest
edit Korean doing her than mine yeah but
yours is flat okay you don't even look
human
okay [ __ ] right here dude has a
[ __ ] melon that's relative to my body
size though that's true proportion
proportion yeah and you're you you you
you have tits yes I do yeah yeah I enjoy
them thank you
they're natural natural thank you right
my girlfriend [ __ ] hates him go so is
she white no she's Korean so she makes
sure she lets me know yeah you got a
Korean do your parents care if you date
out outside of your race it doesn't
matter if they're outside of my my
ethnicity or race she just has to speak
cream
because dude do they speak English
fluently no my mother to speak [ __ ]
English at all that's why my dad does
but he lies that he doesn't you can get
away with it living in LA it's like you
can live in this like bubble of all
Korean speaking I was talking to
Margaret's show last night and I
mentioned because we know we has
immigrant parents too
yeah and there's something that American
parents do when you introduce them do
your white friends they dismiss them by
going like this hey dad this is my
friend Alex and my dad will go oh kill
kill kill kill no he's a human being
that he's got a you know eyes and a soul
I think they do that because they don't
know the language and they don't know
really how to communicate with like
American kids or whatever but if they do
it in the most like even you have to
apologize yeah like what my dad came in
and beat my brother with that [ __ ]
keyboard yes naked like it's that kind
of behavior well you your dad was it was
he violent
he was extremely vibe you [ __ ] out of me
all the time with what with his hand
anything yeah he would do this thing
back in the day where he would put out
his fist yeah and then he wouldn't make
me punch my own face into it write that
down I'm gonna do that you work it right
he would literally come on you know why
what's great about that is that you can
now control the pinna mean how bad hurt
but you know you know you and your kid
your little [ __ ] [ __ ] so you don't
want to do so you like yeah I would do
it stuff so many times but I would just
get punched 40 times in the face because
I wouldn't do it correctly for him you
know what I would have done what done is
as hard as I could so he gets buckets
car oh yeah because I would want to go
to school with it I have to go what
happened my dad please help me did you
have to do the thing where you had to
hold the chair over yeah no we get books
books yeah yeah yeah I [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] is like illegal it should be it
should be legal it's straight arm - so
it burns more you can't even we weren't
allowed to bend I had to do on the knees
chair over the head and it was the most
fucked-up situation because when the
chair is above your arms get tired and
so the chair would smack my head because
I would drop it in the ass yeah you're
six one fine
yeah oh yeah oh that's amazing how
violent they are in there yeah my mom
used to lay out rock salt yeah and then
she used to have a meal on it
I got dark real fast and so after two
hours me you know because the rock salts
would cause like wounds and so the salt
would seep into the wounds and Nate
would actually hurt some more yeah it
was intense you kneel on rock salt and
this is this is what in America in the
Philippines oh yeah oh you get away with
murder there you do have this thing
called month ibotta which is like what
is it what is it what is it it's like
our version of like DCFS the child
protect you know child protective
service but it's basically like if you
observe another parent beating up
whatever would ever call this hotline
but it's like everyone's doing nobody
wants to snitch on each other you know
yeah so it's like no I I need to hit my
kid so I'm not gonna [ __ ] snitch on
that [ __ ] hittin her kids
even if she's literally murdering him
you know yeah I've only called I try to
I threatened my parents that I was gonna
call Child Protective Services once in
my life yeah I never did yeah my brother
did it he did he actually did it in July
yeah know what my brother did was saved
my life why what happened the beatings
got so [ __ ] bad that one day my
brother called they came to the house
and they never really intel until I was
on meth remember like the wars I used to
have with my golf clubs with my dad but
there was a time two three year period
where nothing happened because my
brother did that he saved my life my
brother oh I don't know like 11 12 my
brother you're on method 11 no I
13 or 14 oh now did they beat him for
calling no because my brother was always
the good kid oh so he was like the voice
if I would have done it you would never
say I don't you wouldn't see me here
did you so after you called that one
time how old were you when you call
finally it was the dumbest [ __ ] thing
I've ever done in my life because like I
remember this one commercial you know
like we got the [ __ ] white kid it's
like you don't have to take yeah you
know yeah I got that [ __ ] idea and I
hope literally out of note it came out
of me like out of nowhere I didn't
expect it to come out of my mouth and I
was like that's child abuse in the my
doubts I left the room and I thought I
had one yeah came back with the lead
pipe just swung at me I ducked any
shattered a shelf yeah yeah yeah and
then I just cry yeah my mom came in and
she laughed at me
yeah so your mom wasn't on your side no
they were like you know you're a good
cop bad cop yeah greenhouse like worst
cop so my mom was just tackling issue
beat my ass yeah only child know I have
an older brother but he barely ever got
beat
why no the wild one yeah it was the
golden child
I could see it he thought was a
normal-sized head too you know no his
head is [ __ ] human it is my mom had
to get a c-section because I wish she
why was he the golden Chinese he older
he just you know what his nickname asked
of us actually goody two-shoes like he
would never curse never he went to UC
San Diego so my dad's also a pastor so
he was like so my dad would know when
they would ask about the kids they're
like okay well what is your older son
though he goes to UCSD and then he just
would never mention me because what
about your younger son he goes my
uncle's announced that I died I mean I
was such a bad kid that I was never
brought up either and you know and it's
also this is that you literally feel
like a trophy almost right because they
use their you know like all cousin
Chucho there you go you go to Hollywood
and like they're at dinner right you're
going right in your head yeah but they
do that to make belittle you and it make
he thought that that was gonna make me
go all mine he gets straight A's now no
no I'm gonna go the other direction my
mom still does the same thing so and so
you know she's yeah she's a nurse
practitioner now
[Laughter]
it's so revered yeah yeah oh she's a
nurse Wow in the States Wow huh
like it's very head made yeah so what
are your parents what's your
relationship with your parents now it's
pretty good you know my dad and I it's
hard to get along with somebody calls
you stupid your whole life you kind of
like actually you want the funny thing
is I was just in Sacramento and I got
into a huge [ __ ] yelling match with
him and I felt so [ __ ] terrible I
didn't tell her you know I'm 29
you know you're yelling matches yeah
it's because my dad is so funny because
like I felt terrible because my dad
started tearing up at my mom started
terrible you know you're at that age
where you can't just yell at your
parents and you feel good about it and
so how the fight ended was so funny
because my dad looks at me and he goes
you think you're so much better than me
don't you he goes you know what the
difference is between you and me is that
when like when your grandfather I used
to argue I knew I was just like him you
haven't realized that you're just like
me so you'll never win the argument well
they fine if that's true so you're
[ __ ] stupid right because you always
call me stupid Eagles yes I started
cracking the [ __ ] up oh my god and then
my mom starts laughing till she looks at
my dad she goes you're so dumb because
you call me stupid every day but he said
that and we couldn't stop laughing so he
started getting more angry yeah but it's
just you know it was just so comical
yeah yeah and I felt so terrible and
then we started talking a little bit
more and then afterwards I just gave him
a hug because I felt terrible what do
they think about what you do now like
how do you are you able to explain to
them exactly what you do for a living it
doesn't matter what you do as long as
you make money so my dad was proud after
the money came in it wasn't my idea huge
[ __ ] argument because he I basically
brought up some old [ __ ] which I
shouldn't have and it's cuz I didn't
want to go to a university at the time I
wanted to go to the Community College
and go to the University I wanted to and
he basically said he never said that and
so he goes I told you if you want to be
a comedian I said you took comedy
college I thought [ __ ] is a comedy
College
yeah so he doesn't understand what I was
like that doesn't Korean parents don't
even know how show business works yes I
mean my dad got you have to be
movie what do I do everybody right like
I'm supposed to call paramount go yeah I
want to play spider-man yeah like he
thinks that that's how it works when I
did The Tonight Show you know he said
the next day or how much you pay them
get like I like every guest in there
like Congress like no I was invited yeah
you know they don't know how it works
the he thinks that the reason why I'm
where I'm at is because of like I'm not
making enough phone calls
and he just doesn't realize that this is
the best that I can do always give you
ideas like on how to do your comedy
better know just what did you say well
your dad my dad always has like some
kind of stupid joke about what I should
do so yeah like the weird [ __ ] is it's
like even it when it comes to business
so he comes to me one day like about a
year ago he goes yeah you know I don't
use a condom because you know you have a
GoPro clothing ban right I say you want
me to look over Brooke condom what the
[ __ ] that's not why we get into argument
yeah if I tell him it's not a good idea
he goes you don't understand
it's [ __ ] you just don't know what is
going on in the country ever my hands
they don't know anything right so when
they come up with an idea you know you
should be a movie well you know me you
live in a cave you fight donkey you know
it's like that that doesn't make any
sense
you know I had dream you know that you
know it's like you don't know anything
he's never seen a movie in his life when
he got a stroke what you were there
right my dad had a stroke and my mom put
earphones were you there oh when he
cried when he cried yeah he didn't cry
because he was dying and he heard elk
eric clapton
that's why he cried people were going oh
no he's getting older no he's never
heard music before to him it's like you
know mean it's like when with North
Korea when when they played the field at
Philharmonic yeah
played right and Kim Jong Alette people
listened to him people were like moved
by it because they'd never heard before
all Jesus dad's case because he had a
stroke I'm just trying to be more
scientific about it yeah you're not able
to express the way you express things
it's kind of has been short-circuited so
your dad now can only express from what
I've noticed it's either crying or
laughing so like when he even when he's
happy it's very limited now it's almost
as if like he's lost his ability to
express properly because his brains been
affected oh so like even if he's not
necessarily emotional we're reading it
as emotional he could have hated it he
could have been like [ __ ] this so he
ended up crying but that's the only real
kiss he did it's hard for him to express
rage I've seen I've I've seen him multi
yeah he can't express rage anymore no
right what this is here's how I feel get
why I feel guilty it's because when I
was maybe 14 I prayed that he got a
stroke man but it happened like 30 years
too late God God doesn't work in your
time the way you hon it the way you want
it he answers your prayers he does
answer your prayers but he didn't does
it in his own way Yeah right so I feel
guilty about it because I feel like I
did that oh my god you Maya yeah I think
I would have made up because I hated him
or it could just be the high salt in the
rage it could be that the lobby on you
be the look it could be the alarm but it
could be also my prayers you know I
might do a lot of things you actually
pray did you wanted to get a stroke and
die or just have a stroke oh I wanted
him a Vietnamese exit I'll do it again
the hell I'll do it again [ __ ] give
my jack
sir Oh aids at the same time I mean
those are the kind of press I hated him
and I we used to fear him and he ran our
house like a [ __ ] dictator but I'm
telling you this right now I don't know
what happened to me but I really love
him what age was the turning point what
when you started loving her dad when he
got better as as men get older
[Laughter]
[Music]